(crowd applauds)
- Congrats on the Emmy!
- Oh, man, thank you so much.
- Yeah.
(crowd applauds)
- It's so well-deserved.
How did you guys celebrate?
- Well, we were like the fortunate few
who got to actually be
together because we were,
or a bunch of us at least,
were in Canada at the time,
and at that point, Canada was
doing a lot better COVID-wise
than the States.
So we got to all be together
and we all tested and isolated
and all that stuff, so
we got to be together,
which was so amazing because
it was just one of those nights
that you will never, ever forget,
and so it was all such a blur,
and then the next thing I know,
I look over and Noah
Reid, who plays Patrick
and Noah's wife were standing there
with a tray of tequila shots,
and then the next thing I know after that,
I'm reaching for a tequila
shot with Eugene Levy
and Catherine O'Hara and
Dan and all of the cast,
and that, as I recall,
happened more than once,
and maybe more than twice.
- (laughs) And then the
next moment you were
in the bathroom with your hair.
- Yeah, no, the next moment, I was,
actually the very next
day I was on an airplane
to fly to Boston
to start shooting "Kevin
Can (beep) Himself."
- Oh my gosh, you were hurting.
- Mm, I dragged my decomposing
corpse onto that airplane.
But I made it.
- (laughing) I love,
you know what, though?
That is worth it.
I would do, I'm not even part of the show,
and I would've been like, "I'm in!"
That's a great crew.
- [Annie] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- No regrets, no regrets whatsoever.
- Oh my god.